[Music]
All right. Who's excited about evals?
[Applause]
All right. What can I do to get those
juices flowing? Uh I'm Manu and uh I
work at Brain Trust where we build a
platform to do eval bunch of other
stuff. Um so I was thinking we could
just start by uh talking a little bit my
about my own personal eval journey. Now
you might see this picture and say ah
what an adorable little boy absorbed in
his Nintendo 64 video game. But if you
look a little closer, you'll see a boy
who's deeply disappointed with the state
of technology in his society. Because
this boy, he knows that technology is
not meant to be shackled to the
constraints of rule-based systems doomed
to do the same thing over and over and
over. No, technology is meant to come
alive to grow and adapt and really be a
thought partner to mankind. So, I knew
this in this moment, which is why I
decided to devote my career to being a
software engineer in the AI industry.
And so, I dropped the Nintendo and I
started grinding away on le code and
soon enough I landed a job in the
self-driving car industry. Now, we can
all learn a lot about self-driving cars,
but the thing I took away was that, you
know, you can spend all day tuning the
model, changing the architecture, you
know, adjusting the loss function, all
good stuff, but it's never going to be
enough for you to actually ship it to
production, right? I can't say, "Oh, my
image classification rate went from 98%
to 99%. Put it on the road." Right? We
need some way to you know contextualize
this model and understand if it actually
works for our real world application.
You know does it avoid pedestrians? Does
it negotiate traffic scenarios
appropriately? Does it obey the law? All
this stuff we actually need to
understand. And how we're going to do
that is with eval. Now you know the
whole point here is you know eval aren't
just unit tests for AI. They're not just
for finding regressions, right? If I
didn't have evals, the only way I can
get any signal on my changes is by
shipping it to prod and then getting
signal, you know, in the real world. But
that's expensive. It's slow and
ultimately it's pretty risky. So what do
evals do is it's kind of like if you
invest in good evals, you're kind of
building a laboratory that lets you run
experiments to your heart's content and
do 90% of the product iteration loop
before going to prod and then now you
can ship much more quickly, much more
confidently. Um,
now
furthermore, if you actually apply the
same metrics from offline to your online
production data, you now have datadriven
signal about which examples in prod are
going to be most useful for that next
iteration loop. And so with all of this
knowledge, I was I my eval journey had
completed and I transformed from this
guy to this guy. So success. Now, if
this heartfelt childhood story isn't
enough to do it for you, you don't have
to take my word. You can take the words
of all of these tech luminaries. We have
Kevin While, Gary Tan, Mike Kger, Greg
Brockman, all extolling the virtues and
the necessities of eval. And surely if
they're all saying it, there's got to be
something to it. It can't be a total
scam. So there's got to be some there's
got to be something worth checking out
here.
So with all that buzz, I made my way to
Brain Trust where our goal is to sort of
build the dev platform to of course let
you do eval but also do all the things
that go along with it. So that involves
you know tweaking prompts and
experimenting in the playground. It
involves logging data and sort of
getting the observability component and
kind of connecting all those together in
this beautiful data flywheel so that we
can we can let you build the data
flywheel to let your AI dreams come true
because that's really what what we're
here for for
now. I know this was a dense and
contenheavy presentation. So I'll try to
distill it with one simple message which
is that the key to industry
transformation.
The key to success
is evals eval.
[Music]
Woohoo.
All right. Thank you. Please join the
eval track Golden Gate Ballroom B. I'll
see you there.
[Music]